diamo pure inizio oggi ragazzi un altro
video con una fetta di dubbio design
estetico bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo non vi dò io sono come sempre
il vostro i gay che vi dice cose della
vita che succedono manco i tg allo
ragazzi questo è un discorso che può
sembrare il click day il titolo
incredibile non lo è e non lo è neanche
un po in realtà sono incredibilmente
serio in questo video perché c'è una
cosa che io non vi ho mai detto la mia
famiglia è strana di fatto ragazzi di
avere una famiglia strana in realtà non
so da che cosa
da che cosa è dovuto perché non lo so me
lo so spiegare
comunque ragazzi ci sono dei componenti
anche della mia famiglia che hanno fatto
cose incredibili
a partire dal presupposto che io ho
tanti cugini ma tanti c'è proprio mia
nonna ha avuto sette figli di cui
l'ultimo è mio papà perché voleva
assolutamente un figlio maschio di altri
sono tutte figlie femmine quindi
immaginatevi dei tavolate di natale sono
lunghe quindi o svago nate di cugini tra
cui delle eccellenze a parte me
ovviamente è la cazzata del giorno
l'abbiamo detto o un cugino che è andato
al consiglio europeo per fare da
traduttore per appunto la questione
coronavirus quindi ero lì importanti o
un altro cugino che ha vinto il guinness
record quindi siamo in due ad avere un
tesoretto di famiglia uno e lui e
l'altro sono io per i capelli più
disordinati nel mondo vabbè incredibile
allora questo non è un video per
prendere per il culo sono serio sono
serio o un cugino coming soon record e
ve lo devo raccontare perché non è
meglio non è mai uscita fuori sta cosa
ma bel racconto perché parite ai ragazzi
di mourinho si chiama stefano ghisolfi e
non è mio cugino di sangue ma è
acquisito perché
lo zio che ci lega è ovviamente da chi
doveva essere il buonissimo zio toni
master baffo mi ha presentato la sua
temi tra cui stefano che è diventato mio
cugino acquisito lontano un cugino col
binocolo però a mio cugino
questa foto con mio cugino che ce ne
saranno cinque come potete vedere lui è
quello subito alla mia destra e io sono
quello tutto fiero
forse questo fotogramma io non farla
vedere però fa niente molti di voi
magari io conosceranno già in alta
perché abbastanza conosciuto ed è uno
dei climbers arrampicatori più famosi
del mondo in realtà perché ha vinto un
sacco un sacco un sacco di premi ha
partecipato al guinness record che non
posso mettere per questioni di diritti
perché va beh era mediaset quindi prima
che mi facciano un bruciore culo così
lasciamo verde ha visto che su youtube
non c'è appunto gli in natura e che
operando sia dei diritti ho visto che
però c'è ninja warrior che cosa inizio
warrior ninja gorio ragazzi e tipo è
tipo da cashes cast però molto più figo
molto meno trash è molto più difficile
secondo me è che un programma punta
televisivo americano è colui che ha
partecipato ho visto che c'è su youtube
faccio una mini reaction lista che
secondo me merita un sacco let's go ecco
questa mia cugina questo il mio cugino
sangue mio non è vero nel sangue mio
però molto molto simile cioè è un sangue
che si avvicina credo tavolo già pista
sta roba e c'è lui che fa il percorso di
ninja warner mamma mia quanto tempo fa
tra l'altro 17 facendo un sacco di tempo
e noi in famiglia abbiamo sì talenti
c'era sempre lui fa questo io ogni tanto
vinco happy
insomma vedete che in famiglia comunque
c'è dell'agilità ma vedo che si
destreggia abbastanza bene ecco io sarei
caduto praticamente al primo anello anzi
non mi sarei neanche aggrappato e credo
con l'agilità un giorno dobbiamo fare la
strada un giorno vado pu li facciamo
begins
non è stato lui e walter e mio zio
sempre acquisito una curiosità di tutto
sto casino è che quando noi facciamo
appunto le tavolate di natale abbiamo da
raccontare un sacco di roba da
raccontare tutto in video e cose eventi
che faccio e lui e racconta di quante
pareti ha scalato di quante volte è
stato sull'everest insomma non ci si
annoia le nostre cene di natale ve lo
assicuro e poi anche divertente vi
invito ragazze ma stiamo tanto una
cucina per tutti comunque ragazzi non lo
ricordavo così difficile io non avrei io
non avrei mai io non riuscì eco come
stanno adesso non riuscirei a stare cioè
fermo cioè senza fare questa cosa che mi
aggancio sopra fermo non riuscirei a
stage bravo walter che si vede che non
non supporti per niente tuo figlio per
niente madonna il buon walter meister
bakkali tutti d'altro mi pare non vorrei
di una cagata mi pare che questo
percorso non avesse vinto nessuno
prima e quindi mi pare sia stato il
primo non lo so è questa parte
difficilissima ma toni ma io non
riuscirei veramente da che attaccarmi al
soffitto tutta fermo
ok anno è finito anche per questo tipo
storico ad e fare un salto nella madonna
che iron man
gli ha sputato pure il fuoco ci
mancavano gli effetti speciali va beh
posso fare volendo ragazzi posso fare un
gameplay mirror's edge che un gioco che
di scalare dei palazzi o assassin's
creed anche se forse avvicinarmi così
bravo della città di tutti guardali
guardalo walter bravo alter dove zio
toni tutto questo è no ragazzi e questo
questo orgoglio familiare cioè non avete
capito che per me è come stessi
guardando a finale dei mondiali
incredibile l'ho già vista quindi so
come va a finire però è sempre bello poi
ecco come sono riguardasse italia
germania del 2006 le stesse emozioni c'è
sempre bello riguarda sta roba
klaus dei browser un giorno mi dai un
decimo del tuo muscolo dell'hub del
braccio destro 6 voglia non mi fa schifo
grazie mio cugino
lo so che fa strano non vi dico le cose
però è veramente questa volta anno aveva
fatto anche una pubblicità da qualche
parte io ero in metro a milano e l'ho
visto giusto cartellone detto trovi
cugino o la mia famiglia è molto strana
ragazzi comunque il video ragazzi non
finisce qua perché ho deciso di portarvi
un ospite speciale in questo video
quindi lasciamo lo spazio qua a sinistra
questa è la destra alla destra del video
perché abbiamo in chiamata il buon
stefano
eccolo ciao steve
bene bene poiché sa in garage degli assi
sicilia c'eri tu anche durante lavorante
ma ti alleni vecchia ascolta se il
titolo commentato tutta roba del ninja
warrior perché era da un po che non la
guardavo perché a riguardo una volta
all'anno tipo la finale dei mondiali del
2006 ho appunto detto ai ragazzi insomma
chiacchierato un po per descrivere il
fatto che siano imparentati in modo
strano per parentela acquisita tramite
bio toni praticamente esatto e niente
quindi l'unica cosa che volevo fare
era già che ci siamo fatti un paio di
domande so che tra di noi siamo
abbastanza crisi perché ci conosciamo
però sono due o tre domande al ruolo
ok ciao ragazze ho una veste di
giornalista che non ho mai avuto nella
mia vita quindi adesso so cosa e come
come si sente il giornalista di fare
domande di solito fa vedere la tv uno
sfondo che mi piaceva fare cosa madonna
ma te lo sei montato da solo quello ma
amici praticati questo non si sa perché
felice muro beh certo bellissimo in
realtà non sono mai stato lì adesso che
ci penso che una volta vorrei provato il
muro di anche solo per vedere quanto
faccio schifo per sarebbe divertente
questo chiedero certo anche quello
normale per me è impossibile quindi
figura di questo tutto inclinato allora
ascolta la prima cosa che ti faccio so
che tu hai vinto una miriade di titoli
vincerò qual è stato il titolo perde più
significativo in generale tra tutti ci
sono più bello covinto francia che ho
vinto adesso livello perché jolie è
molto vicino all'italia ha cresciuto
meno quindi c'era a parte migliaia di
persone a farmi schifo e c'erano tutti
italiani tutti i miei parenti miei amici
è quindi stato anche il momento che
bello vince vola era l'unico che ho per
questo di grande e veloce ragione io
c'ero
dunque volta le 00 quella volta lì non
c'era quindi potrei uccidermi ha
spiegato a mia mamma tutta stefano va
bene io non c'ero ragazzi perché sono
uno stronzo però la prossima volta vengo
promesso
ascoltarlo no non lo è però mi
piacerebbe un sacco di una volta èlite i
ricordi per caso il periodo in cui ero
venuto alla b side che ragazzi al design
è tipo da la prima palestra di
allenamento per chi fa climbing almeno a
torino lo era
e io ero venuto una volta perché
comunque io facevo arrampicata per
stefano poi ho mollato dopo due mesi
però siamo sono venuto su ti ricordi
quella volta all'interno venuto al
climbing più o meno 6 cos'era successo
non te ne ricordi ma guarda che io non
lo sai anche te priviero veramente
venuto a faccia cosa è ero talmente mag
rettino che vanno guardate m'han detto
ok da fare è caduta tutta la pena giusta
il tuo babbo e segnatamente la claudia
che quella dai ciao raga buona buona
giornata ma la serata e ci siamo presto
ciao ragazzi in bacio di ragazzi questa
è celiamo possiamo i ragazzi spero che
questo stranissimo video barrani action
barra intervista a barra vi spiego
quanto è strana la mia famiglia vi sia
piaciuto
noi ci siamo domani con le passioni di
schede a cannes ha lasciato un commento
se conoscevate già mio cugino sono lo
conoscevate conosceva telo e noi come
sempre ci vediamo al ragazzo
[Musica]